hong kong's parliament will in effect
cease to have any opposition that's when
the resignations of 15 pro-democracy
lawmakers come into force
they resigned some two weeks back to
protest a law passed by beijing
that gives the government the right to
expel lawmakers
without due process the resignations
mean
the city's pro-beijing administration
will be able to pass
laws without even a murmur of protest
lawmakers say they had no other option
but to quit
but for many like shoe cartoon it will
mean
not being able to do work that is vital
for many in the city
for hong kong opposition lawmaker shioka
chun
his last week in public office is all
about prison visits
he's going to meet the first man charged
under the national security law imposed
in july
i believe he still has to be in custody
for a year or so
before he gets a hefty sentence i was
told he's having some personal problems
so i applied for a special official
visit today to meet him in person
elected in 2016 sheill is the city's
most prominent legislator fighting for
prisoners rights
he's made over 200 official visits
during his four-year term
and more than half of them to protest
related prisoners
as a council member he gets to meet
inmates in private for an hour each
visit
in contrast to the regular 15-minute
public visits
but with his term coming to an end soon
he will no longer enjoy such privilege
am i can no longer be on the front line
it will be a huge relief for the
correctional services department
as i can't put pressure on them anymore
it's a shame as there's still so much i
want to do
but i have to leave office to show
solidarity with the democratic camp
together hong kong's pro-democracy camp
resigned on mars earlier this month
in protest at the expulsion of four
other lawmakers
catalyst for the action was a beijing
resolution giving hong kong authorities
power
to unseat politicians without having to
go through the city's courts
shill kachan is counting down his time
in the parliament
although he could see this day coming it
still came as a shock
i never thought it would be so fast so
hard
we often say xi jinping is the new
emperor
more ruthless and domineering than many
leaders in the past
probably as bird as mao zedong now we
see
that he could even end one country two
systems
in a blink of an eye after starting out
as a social worker and university
lecturer
she became one of the leading activists
in the umbrella movement
in 2014 and was sentenced to eight
months in jail last year
as a legislator it was a traumatic
experience for him
but he still keeps his belongings from
prison to remind himself of his mission
in the past four years becoming a
lawmaker was a peak of my life
but then i was sent to prison the lowest
point of my life
it was so tough in there and i had to
find meaning of
life by fighting for prisoners rights i
taught myself
i'm an undercover lawmaker in jail i'm
here as a prisoner for the checks on
possible abuse by prison officers
i'm here to monitor the government
since the anti-government movement
started in hong kong last year
over 10 000 people have been arrested
with the rise of a generation of
political prisoners
she will seize the pressing need to
provide support for these young people
and their families
he initiated a pan-friend scheme earlier
this year
and has handled 6 000 letters so far
he plans to organize pre-jail workshops
after he leaves the council
being in prison is losing freedom by
having a lot of time
it is the same with leaving the
legislative council
i will use public resources but in
return have more time to focus on this
particular
issue i don't know how far i can go with
the fight on prisoners rights
but i promise i will go as far as i can
but what does the resignation of
lawmakers like shukachun
mean for ordinary hong kongers it's a
question i'm going to put to 27 year old
connor
who joins me on the line from hong kong
now connor isn't my guest's real name he
participated in last year's
anti-government protest in the city
and is hiding his face for fear of
repercussions
from the government connor welcome what
does
the resignation of all of hong kong's
pro-democracy lawmakers
mean to you
well i think the best time for their
resignation has already passed
and the impact here now on the movement
is minimal so
obviously their move this move has
tremendous news value
but uh if we look back on the movement
there has been multiple points in time
when they could have done this uh for
instance they could have done this along
with
the other localist
candidates that also um refused to
participate
in the legislative council so that's a
opportunity that they missed so i think
uh by now their resignation now it's
more to me anyway it's more like they're
being forced out of the council
and it's not their conscious choice to
leave the council and uh yeah the
effect on the movement in general i feel
aside from the news value is minimal
what do you say to those people who say
that these
lawmakers being absent from the
legislative council now
is the death of democracy in hong kong
do you see
democracy as having died in hong kong
oh definitely yeah so uh to me
along with the rule of law right it's
been dead for quite some time now
and it's just now that the people are
beginning to see
that it's been dead for quite some time
it's only because i think um
the public tend to have their hopes
pinned on these uh
more established pro-democracy or
pan-democratic
leaders in before and uh seeing them
fall just
shows them the uh end of the facade
that there is democracy and rule of law
in hong kong so yeah it's a
they're just it's just reckoning with
the fact that it's been dead
yes where does that leave the
pro-democracy movement
in the city a movement that you yourself
participated in
domestic resistance has a lot more
restrictions now than they used to
but it's still really pivotal to
the movement in general i think a major
shift
going forward would be a shift towards
the world stage and the international
stage
because obviously with um a lot
of the movements leaders being exiled
most of the proponents have moved
to towards the uh international
community but then
going by your argument that would
suggest that uh within hong kong itself
there aren't any avenues left to protest
or to stand up for
democratic rights hence it would appear
that the democratic movement in hong
kong itself is dead
right um so yeah i don't think the
movement's dead it's just been
that the course has been changed and a
lot of the methods needs to be changed
as well along with changing times
yeah so it's not dead it's just
functioning in some other ways
i think domestic resistance what is the
kind of domestic resistance you're
talking about
right so i've seen a lot of
things being proposed by leaders of the
movement
so um one uh two things that i've seen
in the past couple of months
it's um a push by a lot of grass move
grassroots forces towards
the rebuilding of a hong kong economy a
more diverse hong kong
economy with the um central planning all
and all that
hong kong for the past 20 years after
the handover
in that time frame we have lost a lot of
our domestic produce and a domestic
industry
uh we we were we used to be in the face
innovative proponents in um
tech and manufacturing um but that's
been dead
for quite some time and we are all
putting everything into travel and
financials
so i think uh seeing a grassroots
push towards the revival of a hong kong
culture
and hong kong community that's a way of
resistance yeah
so yes that's the main thing
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for speaking to us
connor speaking to us from hong kong
thank you
you